oui le texte n'est pas acceptable en
l'état
c'est pour ça qu'on va le discuter nous
sommes favorables à ce qu'ils aient une
réforme de la constitution
mais y'a pas que la constitution et la
loi organique et la loi simple c'est
assez complexe mais il faut en discuter
notamment sur ce qui ce qu'on appelle la
fabrique de la loi c'est-à-dire les
conditions dans lesquelles on vote la
loi et le bicaméralisme avec les
commissions mixtes paritaires le droit
d'amendement pour chaque parlementaire
tout ça va faire l'objet de discussions
ici d'abord à l'assemblée nationale et
puis ensuite au sénat à l'automne
le président du groupe la république en
marche à l'assemblée richard ferrand a
déclaré jeudi que sauf mauvaise foi je
le cite de la part des sénateurs les
deux chambres devraient pouvoir aboutir
un accord commun est-ce que ça
sous-entend qu'il craint que le sénat ne
fasse échouer la réforme pour des
raisons politiques
écoutez j'ai lu effectivement les propos
du président ferrand je pense pas qu'il
soit de mauvaise foi lui lui non plus
quand
il évoque un certain nombre de sujets
dans les textes tout le monde veut me
semble-t-il aller au compromis
je parle les groupes raisonnable il ya
du groupe
effectivement où le front national ou
les insoumis qui en d'autres options
mais entre la république en marche une
partie des républicains les centristes
je crois qu'il ya une volonté de
discuter de dialoguer trouver les bons
dispositif et moi je suis confiant je
suis confiant on a au début du processus
puisqu'il va être long 1 le président de
la république a dit le gouvernement a
dit d'ici 2019
donc ça laisse du temps on est en
première lecture à l'assemblée et avoir
une lecture au sénat puis ensuite on il
va y avoir une première lecture
concernant les textes organiques et loi
simple c'est à dire c'est pas rien le
nombre de parlementaires les territoires
et puis ça va venir au sénat aussi donc
quel temps de discuter et on connaît un
les thèmes qui importe au sénat est ce
que vous jugez vous que lors de ces
quarante heures de débats en commission
les députés ont fait des passes
suffisant vers le sénat déjà ils ont pas
diverger ce qui est ce qui est bien
parce qu'on pouvait s'attendre à tout un
on avait vu passer des amendements je
veux dire la constitution c'est pas le
règlement intérieur d'un club de
football
on mais pas n'importe quoi dans
l'article 1
la biodiversité les transgenres par quoi
on a vu passer toutes sortes de choses
tout ça est déraisonnable donc on a
introduit par exemple des notions
environnementales
cet article 1 il faut aussi être prudent
pourquoi pas on n'est pas hostile à
l'idée il faut être prudent parce que
derrière on sait très bien qu'il peut y
avoir tout un tas de décret de textes
législatives qui vont à l'encontre du
développement économique ou du
développement agricole
on l'a vu avec eux le sacro saint
principe de précaution et on a vu où ça
pouvait mener donc d'un principe qui est
partagée qui est un bon principe on peut
avoir toutes sortes de développement qui
après compliquer la vie des agriculteurs
des chefs d'entreprise il faut être
prudent sur ce qu'on met dans la
constitution alors ya eu un vote
surprise pendant ces débats la majorité
s'est trouvée prise en défaut sur
l'article 3 qui a été repoussée c'est
l'encadrement du droit d'amendement
vous possédez penser aussi qu'il
faudrait purement et simplement revenir
sur cette idée oublier coûté le droit
d'amendement
la façon dont il est utilisé est pas la
même au sénat et à l'assemblée nationale
donc je crois et au sénat nous pensons
que il appartient à chaque règlement
intérieur à l'assemblée et au sénat
aussi d'adapter en fonction de la
culture de chaque assemblée
la façon dont on traite le les
amendements c'est vrai que qu'au sénat
on est un peu plus restrictif
on a des méthodes qui permettent de
faire des amendements tout en n'étant
pas excessif et un arbitrage qui se fait
avec les présidents de commissions donc
l'article 41 articles 45 nous on a déjà
une utilisation rationnelle de tout ça
un mot rapidement sur le congrès qui
aura lieu lundi emmanuel macron
s'exprimera devant sénateurs et députés
réunis
il fera le bilan de sa première année du
quinquennat tracera les perspectives
pour l'année suivante
mais il ne pourra pas entendre les
discours des parlementaires ni leur
réponse est constitué d'un
constitutionnellement impossible
est-ce qu'il faut changer la
constitution pour que cela devienne
possible moi c'est une idée que j'avais
on peut en parler c'est vrai que au
parlement européen par exemple président
de la république quand il y va il peut
rester pour écouter les orateurs
là c'est un peu solennel déjà grâce à
nicolas sarkozy le président peut venir
devant les parlementaires il pouvait
aller devant le congrès des états unis
mais ils pouvaient pas venir devant les
parlementaires français
donc grâce à la réforme de 2008 le
président peut venir
maintenant il parle à présent discours
et tout le monde
enfin chaque groupe s'exprime
et tout ça est un peu comment dire
formelle surtout quand c'est donc moi ça
me choquerait pas qu'il puisse rester
maintenant c'est vrai
institutionnellement certains puristes
de la vème république craignent que le
président puisse être mis en cause par
les parlementaires et qu'il puisse y
avoir une forme de responsabilité du
président alors qu'elle n'existe pas
devant le parlement
je crois qu'on peut essayer de trouver
une écriture qui permettrait que le
président puisse rester et entendre ce
qui lui répondent